hi friends
hi Mia
hi
you don't trust me
oh did you just say no did you just say
no
did you just say no
come
on
I love you oh stretch stretch stretch
stretch
you're the best you're the best girl
okay so taika hi how you doing
okay
okay so take us to school that's why
it's very quiet
Papa didn't make the bed we have this
rule between each other that whoever
gets out of bed first makes the bed I
mean whoever gets out of the bed last
makes the bed okay I'm not mad at him
because man
he's been flying all over the place
um filming a bunch of content he was
doing JK news he did a bunch of barbell
stuff
um we're really investing in properties
and land and stuff right now so he's
been flying all over the place for that
so he's been catching up on some sleep
so I'm not really hating on him it was
more so me being a little bit more
insecure that I just showed you my bed
that was a mess and it's already like
the afternoon
that's the truth
so now I don't have to explain myself
and you expect me as I am I'm so excited
so this
Friday we've been planning this okay
we've been talking about this four
months planned it for maybe a week
um but one of my girlfriends is getting
married and we're having a bachelorette
party for her she wanted to go to Austin
so we're all going to Austin on Friday
and we're doing a stereotypical thing
where she's black she's wearing them
she's what the she's wearing white
and we're all in black
um
and
of course you know what time it is I
went shopping baby
um I'm not
okay a little bit more of the insecurity
that I need to explain okay because I'm
getting caught right now okay you're
catching me I'm showing you guys my
okay I'm so sorry I'm friending
a lot but I use this as a excuse
to buy more shoes I'm like oh I can't
wear What's in my closet that's so
boring I've worn it already
so it means I got more it's a child
home and you're really gonna see what
mood I'm in these days usually if you've
been following for a minute you know
that I'm a crazy ass truster and I like
wearing a bunch of loud bold colors
patterns okay moderately bold because
I've seen some people online that go all
out I'm like in the middle
now I'm wearing nothing but black white
muted subtle
Serene calm colors and this whole batch
of clothes that I'm about to show you is
literally only white black
cream
tan
finito the end
that's it
you ready okay so some of this stuff is
casual the other stuff is
kind of dressed up
but we'll see what I keep and we see
we'll see what I don't keep
I've given you guys this tip before and
I'll do it again Aces is one of the
greatest ones to allow me to do this and
I love them that's why I keep going back
to them and I keep throwing all my money
to them I do want to let you know and
preface this by saying this is not
sponsored by Asus even though I've spent
like a fortune ASO sponsor me
God damn it
but now I don't really care if you
sponsoring right now
um I'm still gonna shop with you anyway
so what I like to do is I just like to
put a bunch of in my shopping cart
that I first of all before that I create
my boards or like lists wish lists if
you will and I have like they're all in
categories I'm a psychopath for
categories and organization so I have
things like swimwear
um tops bottoms shoes heels sneakers
pants
um denim
sweaters jackets so they're all in their
own different categories and um you know
I like to do window shopping so I'll
just like scroll on the app and then I
just start favoriting things and then
when I have an event to go to that's
when I go in there and I start like
really adding things into my cart
um with the Eva in mind and then I'll
order a bunch of try it on you guys
have seen it so many times try it on and
then very neatly try it on so I wipe off
the deodorant I make sure I don't have
any perfume on because I own a business
I understand what goes back into returns
and all that stuff so
even when I open the bags I try to keep
the bag as original as possible I even
fold it as close to how it came prepped
in the bag because I mean I know they
still have to inspect it if they do
their due diligence they have to inspect
and all of that but we're in 2023 now no
one's shopping in person
or at least that's what I think you know
coming from a person that doesn't leave
her house anymore like I'm an absolute
hermit now things in 2022 I mean
thanks to 2020. I don't leave my house
anymore so that's gonna also include
when I shop I'm just gonna shop a ton
keep what I want return what I don't
want get my money back
until they change this policy I'm gonna
keep doing that there's no restocking
feathers under that I've been doing it
for years and
I don't promote it because I don't want
you to have a bad experience and be like
damn it dude I listen to you but if
you're a Gambling Man like me then yeah
definitely go for it put in your
cart try on what you want to try on in
the comfort of your own home when you're
ready to do so but here's the catcher
okay here's the catch here's the kicker
I think I put catcher in kicker in one
word
um you have to return it that's the hard
part that's where they get you you can't
let them win you have to return it okay
repeat after me if I buy it I'm going to
return what I don't want and I have to
return it you have to return it so as
soon as I tried on I start separating
into different piles do I want it I take
it out of the bag put the bag in trash
if I'm gonna send it back
I immediately put it back into its
plastic seal it up put it off to the
side as soon as I'm done trying
everything on I put it back in the Box
seal it all up well I get the return
label seal it all up and it's sitting
there waiting to get returned because if
you wait and you do one thing out of the
steps that I just told you you might not
return it and you might not get your
money back you're gonna get stuck with
you don't want that you thought was
gonna look good and it doesn't look cute
it doesn't fit and you just there there
you go is your money I mean you can sell
it on Bebop or debop or whatever the
it's called
um I had one of those what was mine
called
I don't know I had one of those closets
where you can like buy my stuff and
literally a lot of my stuff is burning
um you can do that but you're not gonna
get the full money that you paid for
whereas if you just return it if you
remember that so
I'm gonna shut enough and I'm gonna show
you what I got
okay so just want to show you my
workstation
I put things again in categories because
I'm a psychopath
bottoms
skirts
sweaters
tops no dress tops accessories
and shoes so I got these I just am a
huge fan of Chucks and I left them for a
few years and I came back last year and
I'm back full fledge I have some black
leather ones and I wanted these vintage
cream looking ones they kind of have
like a slight platform heel it's a
little bit thicker than the usual ones
but
super cute yeah
this is for the Casual days in Austin
also
excuse the mess I'm still moving I've
been using this excuse
for ever
but it will get done I promise one room
at a time
Okay so
dress one holy crap there we go dress
one
um it feels like
I'm attending
a sexy funeral
it looked so damn good on the model
she rocked it so nicely and then there's
me let me show you what it looked like
on the model this is no we cannot do
this we will can not do this
okay but how stunning
does she look bro like hello
she's the reason why I bought it God
damn it looks
nothing like this on me
damn okay well
to my credit there's no real like solid
picture of the dress other than this and
she just rocks it and then
there's me
hello hi
hello
I'm here for a funeral
a sexy funeral
here is option number two
uh it's a little on the cash side wait
can you see that
yeah
I don't know this is like a big
Maybe
I don't know how I like it
hmm
ah
I don't know I'll keep it as a maybe I
might return it after my trip
bring it in the package if I have
nothing else to wear
this might be it but
not Mega happy with it not super
disappointed with it either
it like does a job
we'll see
all right let me show you what it looks
like on the model though
she sold it
look how pretty that looks I don't think
it looks like that on me
excuse me and I have bigger boobs
so they're like kind of sticking out of
the bottom so I gotta like tape it down
or something but she looks hella cute
yeah
duh she's a model but
we'll see
well this skirt was super promising and
something I've been noticing that's just
like so in right now
but such a bummer they literally sewed
these little
hangy taggy thingies into the skirt
itself like how
how lazy
like what in the world this is
horrible dude look at that
how embarrassing
yuck well
it would have been a really pretty skirt
to wear
but that's not happening I'm not gonna
pay for this look at this
it's horrible let me see let me zoom in
you see that it's like sewn
right into it horrible this is horrible
but not as horrible as
where are we at
this side
look let me go down
look
it's like literally in the middle of it
this one's like folded in
so bad
holy you scared the crap out of me
what
I thought it was
um
Mia and then I see a freaking big giant
bulky strong very lonely and horny man
oh no
yeah look at this you think some of our
manufacturers up check out this
skirt what
oh yeah
this is a sample for our new blinds
it's a cute skirt cut it out oh I
thought it was guitar picks
it does look like it's our fixed but
look at this
do you see what happened what oh they
just sewed it in yeah look at this
we all deal with it I guess but look at
this though
wow
hubba hubba you look good do I yeah what
are we gonna do about the face though
the body's getting there
this last one is not even my size my ass
is getting crunched
my longitas are popping out
it's just not cute the quality is not
the best what is happening this is the
first time
I'm not gonna find anything
yeah it's like this velvet
black skirt but yeah
it's not working
we need to do something here it's not
working
so these might be the only promising
things and they fit me a little too
loose on the waist I think Knight of
I just have to cinch the waist a little
bit but everything else fits oh
really nicely I don't know I'll figure
it out
I have to do one of these things hey
that's not bad actually
but these are so comfortable holy crap
play it safe it's gonna be cold
I think I'm gonna keep these out of
everything here
I'm only going to keep these to go out I
haven't even tried all the Casual stuff
come on now but yeah I think I'm gonna
keep these they're really comfy and I
feel like I can wear them
a lot
okay we got something
we got something
that's okay
okay so no more going out here now I'm
just purely doing casual stuff okay
so there's some pants
they wanted just kind of like a baggier
fit on
whoops
I just don't know
how I feel about it yet like I really do
like how loose they are
but something
is just not working for me maybe it's
like this or something or like
I don't know
they're cool
but
something
I don't know what that is
is it the crotch sits too low
is it this extra room here like is it
because you can tell like I went a few
sizes bigger so it fits like it's a few
sizes bigger I'm not too sure
Mia I might step on your nose dude
you're and your pot like why are you
playing with fire look
what if I just look at what
Mia dude out of all the place that you
could hang out here all the space you
choose to be all up in my business
but yeah something
so that tells me I gotta see how much I
paid for it and then I'll know if it's
worth keeping or not
but something
I might not keep it
if we're already saying something that's
telling me something is not right
therefore I need to put it back but I
don't know
I just need to listen to The Voice I'm
I'm not keeping it thank you you're a
real one you're a real one
um
no literally if I like get straight
straight up camel toe that is horrible
yeah tall girl problems
look at how much off the floor they are
no
foreign
not cute at all on my body type
it's just
a big no no no no no no
I love you
okay so this is the next item these
pants
super cute wow she a model baby she's so
pretty okay
bro what
um the no it's um
clearly we're not the same
um
yeah
no I'm too hippie like I have my hips
are too wide for these pants
look how cute they look
bro
I don't even know I look like a
I don't know Tamal I have no idea I look
I'm taking them off Jesus
all right so I have had some
disappointing outfits some disappointing
fits but I think these one two three
four
articles of clothing make this outfit
really good so this is everything I just
bought right now
ready
I think I've entered
my adult phase because
who is she
she's she's a businesswoman you know
she's important
she makes big decisions
I'm saying like she's
yeah she's got it all figured out look
at her she got more light color she
doesn't stand herself
look at this
I mean it's a boxy shirt but you know
you gotta tuck it in some more
there it is
nice right
these symmetrical back
love it
maybe I'm just not meant to dress up
because this is outfit number two and
it's full as too
look at this
sweater I look like a human
teddy bear
but just looks so good there's like a
slit here
nice soft
pants perfect around the waist
like that
I think I'm getting really old because
I'm all about comfort
and minimalism right now or maybe I'm
just really tired
I love it
son I gotta close this so we can
see each other better one second
okay here's the next outfit look at the
detail on this sweater
sweater shirt super boxy again
asymmetrical short in the front long in
the back
comfy asymmetrical pants
super baggy I think I ordered my size
but in tall I don't know if it was on
accident or what I was thinking but to
all of my girls six plus or six feet and
over Asos has you covered with this tall
option it's a little too tall for me I'm
only five eleven
so it that like I need to get these
fixed but I'm also not hating this look
like this is I think what I was trying
to achieve with the other pants that I
felt like oh they're just weird like
this has the baggy component the long
component but then it fits really nice
around my waist so that's the other ones
got to go but
I don't know I'm entering this like
comfy neutral
minimal era who am I
who is she
I think it's
a sign of me being a tired ass
mom
and I only have one kid man but this one
kid is Bart Quan's kid
pray for me
okay same shirt but just another set of
black pants but these are a little bit
higher they sit higher
um they're wide leg and I just don't
like them they look a little bit too
frumpy for me so nope gotta go see you
later
okay these are just
the pants you guys already saw the
sweater but I love this color damn the
camera's not doing it justice it's like
this really beautiful like sandstone
tan color love it
there's a little strappy straps
give it to me I'm for it
I'm in a neutral heaven right now and I
can't believe I'm playing this but
I love the way it looks so clean
okay so that's it for this
Asos Hall tomorrow I am receiving a
package from nastygal and that's
specific to
um this travel so it's a little bit more
on the party side I don't have as much
as I had here because here was like 90
casual
um so I'm gonna try that on tomorrow so
wait and we'll just I'm gonna add it to
this video so just wait for me